[Musique]
elle fait chaque année la une de la
presse hexagonale
la franc maçonnerie mystérieuse et plein
de décorum elle suscite curiosité ou
roger
mais quelle est sa présence en
martinique nous serions selon certains
la région la plus basse soumise est de
france les frères et soeurs sont estimés
à 3 ou 4000 répartis dans près de 70
loge chefs d'entreprise cadres
d'administration journaliste politique
nombreux sont ceux qui ont enfilé
l'écharpé mais le secret sur
l'appartenance reste la règle d'or
un secret qui protègent autant qu'il
dessert suivez-nous aux portes des
temples
[Musique]
si emma ce cri du coeur c'est une
participante du cénacle de 2015 consacré
à la franc maçonnerie qui le pousse il y
aurait en martinique deux fois plus de
maçon que la moyenne nationale entre 3
et 4000 frères et soeurs
eric arcil héloïse et l'un d'entre eux
est affiliée à la grande loge nationale
il est aussi journaliste à france
antilles est l'un des rares à afficher
son appartenance jusqu'au bout des
doigts cette attirance pour la franc
maçonnerie
il explique par le même réflexe que
celui qui a conduit les martiniquais
vers la fonction publique
la maçonnerie représente comme
l'orfèvrerie comme le fait de pouvoir
porter des chaussures une lutte des
batailles cerny ce qu'on appelle les
luttes servile quand on regarde
l'évolution sociale
des neiges en couleur ça ne veut rien
dire dainese et passe par des
professions libre des professions de joe
livre sa vie joue thiérache a fonctionné
[Musique]
la franc maçonnerie autrefois réservés
aux blancs devient symbole de conquêtes
sociales et de contre pouvoir à
l'oppression coloniale s'y retrouvent
alors tous les notables de martinique de
cyrille bissette à louis des étages
victor sévère ou encore joseph la grosse
île hier ils ont tous prêté serment
[Musique]
mais avant d'aller plus loin pour les
profanes comme on appelle les noms
masson voyons l' architecture de la
franc maçonnerie
[Musique]
d'abord il ya les obédiences grand
orient grande loge de france droits
humains ordre initiatique de la royale
les obédiences sont des dizaines
on peut y penser comme à des écoles au
sein de ces écoles il y aurait des
classes environ soixante dix en
martinique appelés loges ou ateliers
quand ils le peuvent tous se réunissent
dans des temples au lamentin à ducos ou
encore à tartenson
et que font-ils donc dans ces temples
des rites des travaux avec un objectif
affiché s'améliorer méchaal morose fut
conseiller de l'ordre au grand orient
qui nous a ouvert ses portes
[Musique]
valeurs universelles donc de tolérance
de respect des autres d'un monde de son
prochain certain nombre de valeurs
humanistes ce sont des engagements que
vous prenez déjà pour travailler sur
vous même parce que le but de la franc
maçonnerie et de s'améliorer soit pour
ensuite pouvoir améliorer la société la
gloire du grand architecte de l'univers
au nom de la franc-maçonnerie universel
comme c'est un ordre initiatique il y à
des rituels spécifiques à toutes les
étapes pour y entrer par exemple le
candidat a les yeux bandés les images
que vous voyez ont été tournées en
france nous n'avons pas eu le droit d'en
faire autant en martinique
s'il est accepté le candidat devra
ensuite assister aux réunions sans
parler pendant un an
il jure le secret sur l'appartenance des
autres il est alors apprenti
une fois intronisé il existe des signes
de reconnaissance spécifique des
manières de se saluer de plus en plus
secrètes
à mesure que l'on monte les grades et
des accessoires que ne renieraient pas
les amateurs de jeux de rôle
à cause de tous ses secrets et ses rites
la franc maçonnerie n'est pas forcément
en odeur de sainteté auprès de l'église
catholique et dans l'opinion publique
quand on promène son micro dans les rues
voilà ce que l'on entend ouah c'est une
secte
voilà des sectes qui est sec d'élite
ces insectes pour moi c'est une secte
on est gâté pour moi aussi pourquoi pour
ceux qui viennent me dire basse avec à
peu près
et c'est encore plus frappant au sortir
de la cathédrale c'est tout diable je
pense pas les chrétiens parce que la
france ne peut pas être élu c'est pas
possible
pourquoi ça n'est pas possible d'être
les duos avec johnny quand toi dieu donc
formation c'est être contre dieu à mon
avis à mon avis c'est être contre dieu
parce qu'on ne peut pas servir deux
maîtres
moi je ne sais rien sauf qu elle m je
sais pas l'autre
dans le casting des théories du complot
les francs maçons figure en bonne place
sur youtube
des accusations que ne reprennent pas
leur compte les responsables de l'église
mais il n'en voit pas pour autant leurs
paroissiens dans les temples maçonniques
bien au contraire l'archevêque david
macaire s'est exprimé dans une catéchèse
en mars dernier peut-on à la fois être
franc maçon et servir l'église
on ne peut pas à la fois avoir la foi
fait de considérer que le chemin vers
dieu vient d'abord de dieu et moi
ensuite je m'exprime dans le champ que
dieu m'a donné
et de notre côté dit je n'ai pas besoin
d'une révélation pour comprendre la
vérité des choses
pourquoi cette réponse si catégorique
alors que certaines obédiences comme la
grande loge nationale prononce leur
serment sur la bible nous avons demandé
des éclaircissements à l'archevêché à
démarche de foi des tutsis une démarche
d'obéissance donc cette autorité dans la
société secrète elle est envisagée il y
aura nécessairement un moment donné
j'allais dire conflit d'intérêts sur la
question de la fraternité la fraternité
c'est pas les frères de loches la
fraternité pour le chrétien c'est tout
homme tout homme est mon prochain
voyez l'ésotérisme il est un peu gênant
parce qu'il est réservé à ceux qui sont
choisis qui sont appelés à entrer dans
l'initiation qui sont acceptées parce
que tout le monde n'est pas acceptée
nous sommes d'accord de chrétiens tout
le monde peut venir
tout le monde peut entrer d'initiation
l'esprit-saint les données totalement
par les sacrements de l'initiation le
baptême la confirmation à l'eucharistie
reste que la relation entre la franc
maçonnerie et l'église n'est pas sans
évoquer une certaine rivalité
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'estime un curé
français pascal vézins exclu en 2013 car
franc maçon
l'église fortement structurée dans un
système hiérarchique ne peut tolérer une
autre authority que la sienne
[Musique]
une influence sur la société qui
concurrencerait celle de l'église
mais alors quelle est la portée de cette
influence et qui sont les franc maçons
martinique
[Musique]
ils sont rarement ouvriers plus souvent
architectes chefs d'entreprise cadres
votre médecin et peut être franc-maçon
votre mère l'est sûrement il faut pas
sous-estimer le
le poids le poids de la maçonnerie de
dans certaines mères si athènes décision
si je vous dis par exemple aller sur les
34 communes
combien il y aurait deux mers maçon je
pourrais difficilement vous en parler
parce unique système loin il existe une
loi qui veut que
on ne peut pas dévoiler un frère alors
je vous demande pardon
certains majorité mr raymond saint louis
augustin là était de fort de france
il appartient à l'ordre initiatique de
la royal dit ouattara et on parle très
librement quand il était maire il
n'était pas le seul frère au conseil
municipal de la ville ne sommes que nous
étions aux maçons
plus de la majorité municipale nous
serons commerce c'est comme deux coqs le
conseil s'est passé comme du bas vous
verrez les masses ont occupé dans
l'échiquier potes dans l'échiquier
politique tout l'échiquier politique
pour le front national gène et duch
rivaux du tout le reste
devenu macho qui pour aller vite
quichotte doite de qui soude à gauche en
martinique aussi moi c'est une caution
il ya des maçons dans tous les chèques
et politique à ma connaissance rue des
francs maçons dans tous les partis
ce jour là il ya un colloque sur
l'europe tous les politiques ils sont
nous cherchons donc la confirmation est
ce que vous connaissez des hommes
politiques parmi donc parmi les parmi
vous qui en font partie
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu à faire la
plupart en font partie vous savez je
vais vous et moi j'ai pas la langue de
bois dans dans dans la justice dans la
police chez les hommes politiques c'est
à dire là où il y a une forme de pouvoir
il y à la franc-maçonnerie nicosie et en
martinique bouclage du parti de rien et
jamais voulu trouver des gens qui
veulent m'aider ou qui veulent faire
certaines choses donc je n'ai pas besoin
de sectes jamais de max
si il y à beaucoup d'élus francs-maçons
nous devrions trouver un ou deux nous
posons la question à tous ceux que nous
rencontrons sur robin est ce que vous
êtes franc maçon a pas du tout je ne
suis pas franc maçon je suis membre
d'aucune loge je n'appartiens à aucune
obédience d'aucune sorte
voilà est-ce que vous connaissez des
politiques qui sont formation jeux wii
gens connus vous pouvez nous dire qu'ils
n'ont donc mais il leur appartient de se
développent des volets est ce que vous
êtes franc maçon non je ne suis pas
parce que vous connaissez des politiques
qui sont francs-maçons
oui mais ça ne m'intéresse pas je ne
vois pas l'intérêt de cette question
parce que je considère que ça relève de
la vie privée
je peux vous dire que je n'ai jamais été
franc-maçon et que je ne le suis pas
vous êtes franc maçon est ce que vous
connaissez des gens qui sont
francs-maçons mais dans le milieu
politique
oui je connais oui effectivement est ce
que vous êtes franc maçon alors j'aurais
préféré que vous poser une autre
question parce que je pense que
lettre de palettes à la pas forcément
beaucoup d'intérêt par rapport aux
missions que j'ai j'aurais aimé qu'on me
pose la question peut-être est-ce que je
suis chrétienne catholique les
adventices évangélistes est ce que vous
êtes franc maçon non est ce que vous
connaissez des politiques qui sont
francs-maçons
en fait je sait pas avec certitude s'ils
le sont pas est ce que vous êtes masson
je ne suis pas maçon non pas du tout je
j'avoue que la question monsieur aux
pros mais j'ai envie de dire qu'autour
de moi j'ai oui j'ai des amis qui sont
maçons oui on comprit politique donc
politique oui très certainement très
certainement oui ce que vous pouvez nous
donner des noms ah non je ne suis pas
mon rôle de pouvoir donner le nom des
gens chacun assume chaque assume au
caire petit en train de passer il dit
elle les ailes on son appartenance donc
bon je respecte un petit peu
le respecte monsieur claude lise est ce
que vous êtes masson mais si on répond à
ce type de questions non non non non non
je ne suis pas bien petit à petit en
train de dire que vous l'êtes
voilà peut-être qu'ils pensent que je
suis môme d'une d'une loge le pays
étrangers non est ce que vous êtes franc
maçon non vous avez certes est sûre j'ai
répondu est-ce que vous en connaissez
autour de vous ah oui mais je le
respecte pas hésité
[Musique]
vous l'aurez compris tout le monde
connaît des francs maçons mais personne
ne l'est or dans cette série
d'interviews
au moins trois personnes nous ont été
confirmées masson par d'autres membres
de l'os
à l'ancien conseil général la salle de
délibération affiche depuis des
décennies ce tableau maçonnique
depuis la création de la collectivité
la grande majorité de ces présidents a
appartenu à la franc maçonnerie
mais l' influence de la franc maçonnerie
ne passe pas forcément par les élus dans
les administrations bon nombre de cadres
supérieurs font partie des loges les
témoignages qui suivent sont anonymes
mais émanent de sources autorisées
voici comment ça se passe selon un haut
cadre de collectivités locales
on voit arriver une personne qui va vous
toucher un mot en faveur de quelqu'un
puis une deuxième qui va en faire autant
puis une troisième
c'est comme ça que ça marche il défile
tout ce dont on bureau et disent la même
chose
autre exemple encore plus spécifique
donnée par un deuxième cadre dans une
collectivité de premier plan
les francs maçons faisait leur travail
comme les autres jusqu'à l'arrivée de
monsieur x au cabinet alors lui on a vu
qu'il avait vraiment comme mission de
faire avancer les dossiers des maçons il
prend les dossiers un par an et puis des
blocs et là les frères se sont mis à
venir le voir directement pour faire
passer leurs dossiers et puis tant pis
s'il y avait des choses plus
prioritaires
cette influence souterraine est
également mise en avant lorsqu'on évoque
les affaires judiciaires
elles font alors une tournure
franchement sulfureuse voyant cette
histoire il y a quelques années un
avocat du barreau de fort-de-france
balance une consoeur d'une voiture
l'agresseur est franc-maçon la victime
nous l'un des témoins de cette affaire
également avocat nous raconte l'ambiance
après la plainte de la victime
manor pour un conteneur de la république
était lui aussi franc-maçon
donc si l'avocat de la victime qui a
subi des pressions non pas seulement du
procureur de la république mais du
préfet de l'époque
c'est un feeling histoire impossible et
donc c'est grâce à la résistance y
encourage de l'avocat de la victime de
cette affaire est arrivé en audience on
a découvert comment la franc maçonnerie
pouvait des fois quand et de s'ouvrir à
des leurres d'étouffer une histoire
plus récemment c'est à la faire ces
règles bien que la franc maçonnerie a
été associée dans l'opinion publique
corinne lancé casters alors présidente
de l'université découvre la disparition
des fonds européens
elles se heurtent soudain à une
résistance multiforme conseils amicaux
d'abandonner la faire pression sur sa
carrière
c'est surtout l'identité des discours
qui frappe la présidente
c'est souvent le décalage qu'il y a
entre lattes dans l'attitude de
quelqu'un qui dont vous connaissez les
discours habituellement dont vous
connaissez les postures et qui va se
mettre à avoir des réactions
complètement en déphasage avec ce qui
est attendu par exemple par rapport à ce
scandale des personnes qui vont vous
recommander de ne pas aller trop loin
qu'ils vont essayer de vous influencer
les conseillers de ministres des
sénateurs oui très haut des personnes
qui essayaient justement subtilement
d'établir des relations de proximité
avec moi pour mieux me conseillé de
laisser tomber en essayant de me faire
obtenir quelques avantages à cette
démission dans les conseillers très haut
placé il ya un monsieur qu'on va appeler
on va l'appeler david david bambouseraie
vous le il cherche à vous influencer de
plusieurs manières différentes et un
moment vous le rencontrez
systématiquement sur votre chemin d'une
façon qui fait presque froid dans le dos
racontez nous oui effectivement c'est à
vide dont poudre et j'avais l'impression
qu'il avait le don d'ubiquité
en fait quel que soit le rendez vous que
j'avais dans les ministères ou dans
d'autres institutions
je m'asseyais dont je salue et je
m'asseyais à peine et déjà 6 on me
disait monsieur monbousquet vous saluer
et vous fait savoir qu'il sait que vous
êtes là tous les acteurs ne sont pas
dans l'ombre le soutien le plus
emblématique c'est celui de camille
chauvet alors élu régional
ce franc maçon affirmé attaque plutôt
brutalement la présidente de
l'université et n'hésite pas à
s'afficher avec le directeur du céreq ya
un soutien qui nous dit il n'a rien à
voir avec son statut de francs maçons je
ne sais pas s'ils souhaitent célimène
est un fruit je ne sais pas si c'est
offrir
moi je me retrouve dans cette histoire
de sélénia parce qu'on a voulu coller
cette affaire au ppm l'homme du plénière
et depuis je me bats contre le fait que
l'on veut y associer le ppm à cette
histoire
la formation émoussés les malades qui
vous raconte ça qui vous disent que la
forme il ya des malades qui voit la
forme a sonné par tous il voit pas au
tout mais elle nous avoue garanti matin
sous une guillotine la formation ni n'a
rien à voir avec cette affaire du
citoyen fer sérique bien parce que c'est
la firme externe et moi public
j'ai entendu des gens dire et les
francs-maçons considération que j'ai
invité ni des personnes que je voudrais
dire ça qui est une personne bien placé
ce plan politique je dis je t'invite m
gala qui ne faisait pas tout à l'heure
parce que ça ça me peiné d'entendre
quelqu'un pour laquelle j'ai beaucoup de
tendresse quoi dire n'importe quoi
elle est venue lui dit qu hier
l'opération de libre et tu repartiras
personne libre tu en feras ce que tu
voudras après donc elle est venue
attendue et il me semblerait plus dans
ce discours je n'ai plus entendu parler
de la maçonnerie
[Musique]
l'omniprésence des francs-maçons la
première juge d'instruction du cerf et
demi en était en tout cas convaincu en
quittant le dossier nous disent trois
sources judiciaires concordantes
[Musique]
faut-il en conclure que le serment
d'entr'aide que prononce chaque franc
maçon l'obligent à soutenir n'importe
quel malversations rien d'aussi simple
c'est également un franc maçon olivier
jean marie qui dirige le comité anti
corruption contre le scérén ya et il
n'est pas tendre
en lisant les rapports sur le ciraig mia
j'ai découvert une culture de la menace
de l'insulté de l'impunité de
l'escroquerie de la fraude
autre contre exemple ce sont parfois des
francs maçons qui divulguer certaines
informations à la presse sur des
affaires de corruption au péril de leur
carrière
[Musique]
la fraternité maçonnique a de toute
façon ses limites celles de tout groupe
humain où l'on trouve des amis et des
ennemis
maurice laouchez a quitté sa loge il ya
quelques années pour lui le serment
d'entr'aide que doit prêter chaque franc
maçon jurant de porter assistance à son
frère n'a pas fonctionné les francs
maçons nos jours des pets ne sommes que
des hommes lorsqu'ils voient des des
batailles se livrer à des niveaux qu'ils
estiment trop peu élevé pour eux ils
évitent de sang mêlé et moi j'ai eu
plusieurs difficultés dans ma vie
professionnelle comme beaucoup de gens à
aucun moment je n'ai trouvé aucun franc
maçon pour m'aider à m'en sortir
à aucun moment lorsqu'il avait été
question que soit nommé à la tête du
crédit agricole de la vente unique qui a
quelqu'un qui était franc maçon et que
d'aller dire à paris vous savez vous
allez nous bien un trois mâts sont à la
tête de crédit agricole 2 c'est parce
que vous êtes formations para paie les
pots comprenez c'est parce qu'aux
formations n'ont qu'à passer il joue à
l'oral comme ces formations il pas
reconnaître ma cabaye jeu que vous dites
là c'est vrai j'ai déjà eu des
accrochages bon avec des frères parce
que bon il estime que je n'ai pas été
assez bon
tolérant avec de l'eau enfants qu'il
allait recommander ça fonctionne pas
comme ça
la maçonnerie a d'ailleurs sa propre
justice et une panoplie de sanctions
camille chauvet a lui même été frappée
de deux ans de suspension
les sanctions peuvent aller jusqu'à
l'exclusion je ne parlerai que le lobby
danse à la clé appartiennent au grand
orient de france
nous ne couvrons aucun faits délictueux
ou qu'un frère ou soeur qui
commettraient des choses hors moral et
or de la loi et qui ne respectent pas le
règlement général
la fraternité n'admet pas et n'excusent
pas tout ce qu'il pense qu'en venant
maçonnerie il ferait couvert je crois
qu'ils ont faits et aurait fait le
mauvais choix comme les prêtres
pédophiles que l'on change de paroisses
certains expulsés d'une obédience sont
cependant récupéré par une autre
[Musique]
la morale maçonnique se veut en tout cas
du côté du bien
le progrès de l'humanité l'amélioration
personnel la démocratie en voyant
arriver ces deux personnes dont le
temple de tartenson on pourrait presque
croire à un couple ils appartiennent
pourtant à deux partis politiques en
guerre ouverte
le mime pour charles sainté mais le pp
habits pour nicole la guerre membres de
la même loge au grand orient
leur complicité ne fait aucun doute la
franc maçonnerie et fasse des
appartenances partisanes bon en effet en
masse aux radios en est lancée dans un
mouvement de fraternité dans un
mouvement philosophique aussi de
recherche de l'amélioration de l'être
humain et il n'y a pas de rbm l'ump 2
ppm
ce sont des frères d'armes à sony de ne
pas de mot d'ordre il n'est parfaite ci
fais ça en leur âme et conscience nous
réfléchissons nous regardons nous
faisons le pour mieux contre et
jamais donc au 100 libre
je ne peux pas être gêné c'est que soit
l'autorité qui fasse la promotion ne
suis pas de partir quelqu'un sauf si la
république est en danger alors je suis
obligé de prendre position contre ce
parti qui mettrait nos libertés et la
laïcité quand nous sommes aussi light
la laïcité est un danger à l'oral je
serai obligé de bouger et ça pourrait
aller ça peut vous paraître étrange même
contact physique
et quand charles saint-aimé parle de
combat frontal contre le fascisme il
s'appuie sur une réalité
la franc-maçonnerie se trouve du bon
côté de l'histoire
abolition de l'esclavagé avec cyrille
bissette et victor schoelcher mais aussi
opposition aux nazis du temps de
l'amiral robert c'est en effet un franc
maçon
le commandant tourtes et avec 200
soldats qui prend la tête de la
résistance armée proclamant la
dissidence au camp de balata par un
message radio pc balata à population de
fort-de-france et à toutes les autorités
nous sommes toujours aussi résolu si les
marins tirent sur la population née des
cendres ont immédiatement
stop vive la france combattante sous le
régime de vichy
les francs maçons ont d'ailleurs été
licencié spoliés et même emprisonné dans
ce fortin des trois îles et le lazaret
laisser aujourd'hui à l'abandon
combien de personne je n'ai pas trouvé
le chiffre dans les archives combien de
temps combien de temps mais ça a duré le
temps de l'amiral robert c'est à dire
que bon ce qui n'était pas catholique
machin était enfermé donc donc ce qui
fait qu il y a eu pas mal pas mal de
familles de famille muller qui ont été
inquiétés
plus près de nous lorsque la grande
grève de 2009 menace de dégénérer on
fait appel aux obédiences pour lancer un
appel au calme
une rencontre est organisée entre le
secrétaire d'état en charge de
l'outre-mer yves jégo et les
représentants des deux loges maçonniques
le grand orient de france et la grande
loge nationale de france
toutes ces actions sont dictées par des
principes de rivière où les loire on va
les attendre les principes capitaux de
l'homme le respect des autres et la
dignité de soir la compréhension
réciproque et la tolérance mutuelle la
liberté de conscience
l égalité parfaite l'amour fraternel
amitié fidèle perfectionnement
individuel et l'amélioration collectif
le perfectionnement individuel et
l'amélioration collectif
[Musique]
alors la franc maçonnerie est elle bonne
ou mauvaise pour la société
martiniquaise
écoutons maurice laouchez dans une
déclaration qui peut selon vos
convictions inquiété pour assurer des
cas la martinique beaucoup de francs
maçons contribuer à tenir cette société
c'est une société qui est en crise qui
est en difficulté les migrations le
prouvent les le monde politique patine
on voit bien aujourd'hui qui a beaucoup
de difficulté dans le monde politique
beaucoup de décisions à prendre qui ne
sont pas prises et bien le les francs
maçons sont à la tête de beaucoup
d'associations à la tête de beaucoup
d'établissements d'enseignement à la
tête de service dans l'administration et
dans là où ils sont dans leur profession
ils appliquent les principes mentionnés
qu'elles soient jugées bonnes ou
mauvaises l' influence des francs-maçons
sur la société martiniquaise est en tout
cas réels dans notre reportage les plus
ouverts à la communication nous ont
semblé ceux du grand orient de france
le ouattara a accepté de nous parler
mais pas de laisser filmer l'intérieur
de son temple
les responsables de la grande loge mixte
ont refusé les deux nous avons entendu
de toutes les obédiences des réponses
similaires qu'elles nous ont semblé
sortir d'un livre tant qu'ils garderont
le mystère sur leur appartenance
les francs maçons ne pourront en tout
cas pas échappé à l'adage populaire qui
veut le secret a quelque chose à cacher